ma'am Dam oh I'm sorry what's going on
roll on the window oh I'm sorry
Hi how are you good what's going on oh
no it was just what's Happening Here hi
what's going on one step out of the car
for me I just want to make sure that
you're okay oh we fine all right well
people were well people were a little
nervous oh really yeah oh yeah well
what's going on today oh nothing I went
to go I'm
to mic and it yeah sorry I was doing
my okay I to all right just step out of
the car for me all right please y
[Applause]
sorry watching in the all right what's
yeah I mean like what's going On's going
back here real quick yeah yeah okay sir
thank
you yeah so how long we been have you
been here uh about I talked to my
husband in 20 minutes or so 20 minutes
yeah okay where you coming from uh
actually I went to Car Wash uh near the
um the barracks of the 206 206 the car
yeah wash the truck okay yeah all right
whose car is this mine it's yours okay
do you have uh any kind of
identification on you I do okay could I
have that please sure oh appreciate that
yeah yeah I'm sorry I was just
uh to say to make phone calls so
yeah in fact
um you guys are good thank you I
apprciate thank you I'm sorry I
didn't crazy over here here you go sir
thank
you all right so where you coming from
today Newton yeah Newton H okay I live
right near
um all right so what were you doing here
today where were we trying to go oh okay
I was going to go shop right um to get
some face cream cuz I
hadac yeah where' you get that how'd you
get that I'm working in the yard oh
really we get yep okay so um yeah and my
husband asked me to pick up some dinner
so okay that was it got you one second
hello um just come around the corner so
going towards the uh the
salon all right
yeah
all right I'm sorry so uh Jersey mics
okay yeah yeah we don't have that near
Round new noon yeah okay where' youut
you came up from home uhuh well from the
car wash car wash yeah 206 at the back
way here and then okay yeah all right we
just wanted to make sure you're okay
obviously you're uh you're passing out
here oh no you know I was yeah no I'm
good I'm good sir well is there a reason
why youever passed out here
okay we want to thank Morgan and Morgan
for sponsoring this body cam video I
mean I think it's pretty clear from the
body cams that we cover that it's not
always safe out there when you're hurt
it can be confusing it can be scary you
don't really know where to turn well
Morgan and Morgan is actually the
largest injury law firm in America in a
time when you already have so much to
think about they're going to make it
super easy for you they have completely
modernize the process because you submit
your claim you sign contracts you upload
documents you talk to your whole legal
team all on your phone that's it an
attorney is going to review your case in
just eight clicks also they have 4,000
support staff that can help you too
which is just amazing to think about and
in terms of price well you only pay them
if you win there's no upfront fee so if
you're injured and you want to join the
over three million people that call them
every year you can submit a claim at
www. forthepeople.com
LC body cam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone no just
just just a nice nice peaceful moment I
guess you know day and yeah that's aome
okay yeah all
right hi how you
[Music]
doing yep
yep she passed out when you got here yep
passed out exactly
yeah well at this point not right now
what's what's going on do you have any
kind of medical issues no sir
nothing okay are you any any kind of
medication at all no
nothing Well allery bags but I mean I
don't you know
uhhuh okay what's your phone number
forisa
three and the
qus oh jeez what is going on now I just
tell to cancel oh my goodness gracious
what is happening no you're good they
they were calling me because you were
obviously unresponsive you w they
weren't they were trying to get your
attention but you were unresponsive
sorry I didn't realize okay y a parking
lot I fig just hello no that's fine
that's fine today we're good we're good
right sir yep no that's fine one second
okay I'll be right with you all
right are you feeling like
lightheadedness anything like that no
like that sir okay hey I'm I'm good I'm
good I'm okay nothing nothing much just
sitting the par on the phont of my
husband and that was it I mean okay do
you have a registration to the vehicle
as well yeah grab that
please I was just about to cancel you
guys okay yeah me I'll go back
yeah yep we're we're good right now you
yeah appreciate thank you yep yep
he you can cancel 491 we also
cancel appreciate coming out you guys
out here quick Jesus Christ don't mess
around I like it I like
it what I have to I
haven't yeah we're all up to
date
do you have the updated
one oh you know what uh it's it's it's
shoot it's on my phone uh the new car's
on there huh yeah no it's all run it you
don't have the physical one wait hold on
have the new one mhm I know my husband
supposed to put it in there yep you know
how that goes right
yep prob not but yeah it's if you run
yeah I did all that
online and then also here the insurance
card how about that do you have the
updated one there's that
uh yeah again
everything car one driver is comping
aacc female party the call the emale
Jesus nothing you got all the old ones
huh you got all the old ones yeah you
know everything's up to date though okay
well I'm sorry can you get it up on your
phone do you have app baby uh I'd have
to go through my all my stuff so but
um yeah wa what insurance company is
it we're Progressive okay so you you
don't have the app though uh no no
um
you know he was supposed to put it in my
vehicle all
right okay
um I don't what kind of work are you wi
you're you're a painter or something oh
well yeah I'm an artist I've been I've
been doing some that's the other thing
too I've been renovating the house and
yes okay okay yeah so
what
do I was talking to my husband and um
you know a nice little peaceful moment
for a minute you know andh yeah uh my my
daughter um is in a mental in a mental
uh hospital so it was it was a little
tax how long how long did she go there
she's been out for uh a little while now
so yeah a little while what's a little
while she's uh see St Clair is about
month and a half and it's yeah it's just
been it's been a trying time I how old
is she 14 14 wow that's that's a lot
yeah um so how long was she in there
for two two weeks too long yeah two
weeks two weeks one day yeah yeah
um and it's been an early day my husband
just went to JFK to pick up my son at uh
at the airport he came back from Arizona
yeah so uh yeah was was just like a
little you know I was like just sit here
and okay beautiful day and that's all so
all right just bear with me just going
to run your life okay you know so it's
just a little it's just a little
concerning for us because you you know
we don't want to leave and have you back
behind a wheel oh no no no no I'm good
yeah I'm sorry um yeah I
just
see anything in the car but
she it's like questionable I'm going to
put
on
H how you do
that
all right what's your name I'm sorry
what's your name t t so we just have to
ensure that you know you're going to be
capable of are you like tired or oh no
no no so what exactly happened because I
need we need to try to figure out was it
a medical thing did you take something
that had you passed out where as though
you weren't respons it was just a
peaceful moment outside the house and I
just you know I figured the parking lot
I was on the phone and that's all
nothing more nothing less yeah but yeah
you just fell
asleep yeah a little bit
yeah not not fell asleep I was just I
was doing makeup and I I fixing my face
but not like entirely you know what I
mean yeah oh you but you wen't
responsive to people for so that's that
well I was yeah know um I mean I'm in
the parking lot and yeah I know but
people are trying to ensure you okay and
you weren't responding to them so as law
enforcement of course our biggest
concern is we do not want to have you
operate in a vehicle if you're tired to
the point where you're like unresponsive
behind a will cuz you can hurt yourself
or someone else yeah no I'm absolutely
fine OB no I'm F so do you do you
remember the events leading up to
like falling asleep or passing out or I
was on the phone with my husband and did
you end the call or did you just I
didn't and then from there do you
remember what and I just sat there and
you know the the window down and listen
to music and that was it do you know
about how long you were here uh about 20
minutes I mean I haven't been here that
long um I can go on my fall log
but yeah I don't believe that this is
any cause for alarm it's just no well
it's a cause for alarm for us because
again you're operating a vehicle a
vehicle can be a weapon if not used
correctly so if you're tired to the
point where you're falling asleep or you
know may have taken something that has
your we have to ensure that you're safe
if we have to ensure that the public is
safe so we don't want you behind a 2
3,000 lb you know vehicle like I said I
just did from the car wash uh that was
on 206 the one by the police barracks um
and then that's it yeah so were you
coming over here to shop yes
yes so did you did you make it to shop
or you just not yet I was going to go
get my bags out to go yeah um cuz my
husband wanted me to bring dinner home
so that's all yeah well he's just run
getting your information so when he's
done you know yeah no callose for alarm
I'm sorry I I didn't realize like you
know I just figured out a little
peaceful moment you know what I mean
yeah I was away from the computer I'm
away cuz I I work from home and it's
like I don't know so that's all right
thank
you
I don't know let me
go all right I got this on
here all right yeah we're good this is
going
all right so what's based on
with based on what I saw okay we're
going to take you through some a test
okay to make sure that you're safe to
dve oh goodness okay okay um just before
we get started did you while you were
sitting here did you take anything while
you were sitting here or anything like
that all right all right um You can give
this I'll put it back for you okay okay
thank
you all right so it's going to be three
tests that we going I'm going to do it
for you okay all right all right so come
over this
way okay all right um just a little bit
further back okay watching all
right 3 and 1/4 good time stamp going to
be
testing okay all right uh so before we
get to started do you have any injuries
or ailments that would prevent you from
being able to B balance yourself at all
y nothing like that nothing thing with
your feet or anything like that okay all
right um also do you have any contacts
or glasses do you wear a contact or
glasses no but I do need glasses I got
to go you okay that's you know you turn
44 and that's fine um okay so what we're
going to do is three tests okay the
first one um I'm going to instruct you
it's going to be the hgm okay so what I
want you to do okay see the tip of my
finger okay you're going to follow that
with your eyes and your eyes only do you
understand that yes okay so don't move
your head okay just follow with your
eyes Okay mhm all
right don't move your
head keep your hands to your sides there
you go don't move your
head
don't move your head sorry my ass let's
go is that uh alre
almost
done right now we're going to go
up okay almost done two more two more
times okay all right good all right Next
Step next test I'm going to do is going
to be the walking turn okay what I want
you to do though is get in the starting
position which going to be hands at your
sides feet together actually it's going
to be Heel To Toe right foot in front of
left as so could you do do that mhm go
ahead put go in that start position
now okay keep your arms balanced at side
yep Heel To Toe okay okay stay in that
position while he you the instruction
y get it back heel the toe okay I take
my whatever makes it easier for you no
it's okay you know do you feel
comfortable I walk in these all the time
so I'm just letting you know that before
we get started with the test if you
don't feel comfortable walking your
heels you can take them off yes well I
just usually don't walk like
no it's fine but it it's up to you I
whatever makes you feel more
comfortable yeah I I I just want to make
sure like you know we're good here yeah
that's and that's why don't know if
you're comfortable let's Okay um um all
right let's just
do okay all right so just stand in that
position while I demonstrate the uh the
test okay okay all right so when I tell
you you're going to take nine Heel To
Toe steps forward all right you're going
to Pivot and take nine Heel To Toe steps
back okay I'm going to demonstrate okay
you stay right there okay you're going
to count one two three I'm only doing
three but you're going to take nine okay
on your ninth one you're going to take a
series of small steps okay and you're
going to Pivot and take nine heel the
toe steps back in a straight line okay
you're going to count out loud keep your
hands at your sides at all time making
sure you hit heel of toe okay okay you
got to stay in that starting position
do you understand the instructions I
sure do do not yes and then do not stop
when you start just proceed and finish
this
test all right start position right hand
answer are your sides okay are you ready
yes one
2 four the
toe look down at your
feet okay all right next one is the last
one it's going to be the one leg stand
okay starting position for that is going
to be feet together hands at your sides
okay when I tell you you're going to
lift either foot whatever you choose 6
in above the ground keeping the foot
parallel to the floor to the ground okay
you're going to count 1 1,000 two 1000
nope stay there that was going to stay
yep yep y you're going to count 1 1,000
2 1000 3 1000 you're going to continue
when I tell you to stop okay I'm going
to demonstrate it for you all right when
I tell you you're going to lift it up
parallel to the floor to the ground
you're going to count 1 1,000 2 1,000 3
1,000 4 1,000 5 1,000 you're going to
continue until I tell you to stop okay
do you understand that you're going to
make sure you keep your arms at your
sides look at your toe the lifted toe
when you do it and count out loud
understand and uh what whatever foot you
choose whatever foot you choose just
bear with me one second okay yeah sure
get that starting position
still one
second you ready sure okay and go ahead
okay
1 100 2 100 HS at your
sides keep going keep going yep yep lift
up lift up and
continue take the heels off for that you
know I mean you got to consider mhm
good if you if you like I said that's
why we asked you
beforehand okay you got you got to keep
your arms at your sides commiss do you
want to start again yeah let me take
these off
the I don't think this is wise to do
that because it's you know they're three
in here and I be
painting
okay yeah try doing that
okay all right feet
together hands at your sides all times
lift at six inches look at your foot
count out loud okay go 1 look at your
foot I don't try continue to go
okay count 1 1,00 2 1,00 3 1 4
1,00 6 1,00
okay all right Kissa listen based on
what I see okay you're going to be
arrested for DWI no okay yes turn around
no sir yes turn around put your hand
behind your back oh no sir yepa stop
stop stop
stop oh
no good other
arm I don't want to pinch you so make
sure you're good here
anything like that nothing then she's
going to she's going to she's going to
check you
okay yep she's going to check you hold
on one second no sir mhm why I already
told
you you know I um we're going to do you
mind taking those we're going to take
those glasses off so you don't lose them
okay oh Jesus all right I I to all right
come on no no no no
no oh boy come on this is not
good all right have a seat okay go ahead
have a
seat
you mind thank reach over
you okay read your mirand right you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can will be used against you in
court of law if you have right to an
attorney if you can't afford and one
will be appointed to represent you
before any questioning you can exercise
these rights at any time not answer any
questions or make any statements stay on
the stand
okay you going to secure this car
yeah is there anything you need out of
this out of the car you got a wallet
purse anything like that purse cell
phone all on the front yes
okay wallet purse in the front yeah you
want you want to take it she wants it
yeah you got a cell phone in there
somewhere does she want a cell phone
yeah she said she wants it I just
asked
thank
you one more
time all
right turn
off